in the context of the Russia scandal
we've been keeping you up-to-date on who
from the Trump administration has been
getting worried about the investigation
into the Russia scandal and chosen to
hire private personal lawyers so
recently I told you Donald Trump
lawyered up with Marc kazoo it then he
added another lawyer
Jay Sekulow one of trumps lawyers
Michael Cohen himself hired a lawyer of
his own Jared Kushner got a lawyer mike
pence got a lawyer now the country's top
lawyer Attorney General Jeff Sessions
has himself lawyered up it was first
reported yesterday that Jeff Sessions
has hired none other than his longtime
friend and attorney Charles Cooper who
is a conservative activist shocking
right sessions has a very questionable
background when it comes to race and
social issues so what kind of lawyer
do you imagine Jeff Sessions would be
friends with and hire to represent him
naturally Charles Cooper is a lawyer who
once defended the Christian school Bob
Jones University in court when they were
trying to ban interracial dating on
campus jeff sessions his new attorney
has also defended an employer's right to
discriminate against people who have HIV
we don't exactly know when jeff sessions
hired cooper but he reportedly prepped
sessions for that hearing in front of
the Senate Intelligence Committee last
week Cooper was at the hearing which
prompted speculation about whether or
not sessions had hired him and
afterwards it appeared that everything
Jeff sessions did was something a lawyer
would have instructed you to do right I
can't recall I don't remember I don't
believe so senator I'm going to invoke
executive privilege for Trump even
though I can't actually do that and now
it's been confirmed by Charles Cooper
that he is representing sessions he
refused to say anything else he said to
the Washington Post in an email quote I
do represent the Attorney General but as
with all clients do not comment on
confidential client matters Cooper was
being considered for the Solicitor
General position at the US Justice
Department
he removed his name from consideration
for that role because he didn't want to
go through the confirmation hearing
process saying at the time quote after
witnessing the treatment that my friend
Jeff Sessions a decent and honorable man
who bears only good will and good cheer
to everyone he meets had to endure at
the hands of a partisan opposition that
will say anything and do anything to
advance their political interests I am
unwilling to subject myself my family
and my friends to such a process okay
I'm not really sure Pat why he would be
so worried about it if he had nothing to
hide but fine again we don't know when
jeff sessions hired cooper but sessions
definitely seems like someone who needs
a lawyer at this point is he's in pretty
damn deep well you know cooper
representing the top lawyer in the
country you'd have to imagine that he's
the cream of the crop right yeah but
maybe it's just like how the highest
court of the land is the basketball
court above the Supreme Court chillin
it's kind of a fake thing it sounds fake
to me it sounds pretty damn fake to me
and Jeff Sessions of course at the heart
of the Russia scandal in multiple ways
caught lying or quote not remembering
multiple times about multiple meetings
he had with the representatives of the
Russian government during the 2016
election had to recuse himself as
Attorney General from anything related
to Russia and then during the recusal
and this is where it just gets whacked
out during his refusal he recommended
that Donald Trump fired the FBI director
James Comey who was looking into the
Russia investigation and some Trump
campaign members might go broke before
this entire thing is over you know Trump
has a lot of really rich people in his
cabinet and on his team but he has some
people who were only somewhat rich Jeff
Sessions has a net worth of 7.5 million
dollars it might sound like a lot but
it's way less than some Trump cabinet
members mike pence for example has a net
worth between half a million and a
million dollars Pence's lawyer
reportedly charges nearly $500 an hour
so while a million dollars sounds like a
lot you can rack up a pretty big legal
bill when you're being investigated by
two congressional panels and a special
prosecutor and you're paying five
hundred bucks an hour to your lawyer and
it's long been thought that there's this
oversaturate
in the legal market because I think
there's 1.2 million lawyers in the
country well for country of 300 million
people you just don't really need that
many lawyers there's not that much
demand
I guess Trump is bringing jobs back in
this way as I said yesterday Trump is
creating jobs for lawyers no doubt about
it and it's never a great situation when
lawyers hire lawyers to represent them
for things that they did in their roles
as government lawyers that's a problem
that's a red flag and something you want
to avoid send me your thoughts on this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible by tag adapt
the hosting specialists offering a range
of flexible hosting packages including
dedicated VPS and cloud server options
as well as custom server solutions and
uk-based colocation services for your
business or project taga DAV's web
hosting services support a wide range of
customers and businesses worldwide
including bloggers tech startups
financial traders gamers web developers
and more and taga dave has a really
user-friendly interface so you don't
have to worry about being super tech
savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a 20 british pound
free credit about 24 US dollars to all
customers signing up to give you a
chance to try the service this is a
limited availability offer first-come
first-served for viewers and listeners
of the David Pakman show to take
advantage of it go to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS and use the offer code TDPS
20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration